[Music]
huh hello Craig for years you have made
emotional connections with the ones you
love and for years who have used your
humor to sabotage those friendships
you're afraid of connection that you
afraid to love to put it plain and
simple you don't appreciate your life no
I I share my sense of humor because I
love others knowing how textbook you can
be I'm going to assume you'll try and
talk your way out of this one this is a
recording so don't waste your words [ __ ]
will find on that I wouldn't have said
anything others
hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and it's Joan Humphrey over here so over
at our patreon where you can become a
patron check today by the way one of our
reward tiers is that whatever video you
request whether it be a reaction or
discussion we will definitely do Toni
McGuire he has requested that we do our
top 5 favorite scariest films compiling
this list for you Tony and the rest of
the reject world we wanted to choose
five films of our own making a 10 in
total over yeah I wanted to choose five
films ourselves that not so much from an
intellectual experience but from an
emotional experience because some of
these films that I'm gonna list on my
side are not exactly that's scary to me
now but when I saw them they scared the
crap out of me and likewise for Jon
before we go into this list I want to
make it clear that we are by no means
saying that these are necessarily our
favorite horror films of all time or
that these are the most definitively
scary films of all time we are drawing
strictly from personal experience saying
though at the time whatever age we were
at we viewed these movies these scared
the crap honestly think like maybe
looking at my list two of these are
actually I would consider my top five
favorite horror movies my favorite
horror movies not even on this list 10
so just want to make that clear Jon with
you being the horror buff do you want to
kick this off my number 5 I went with
the most recent title on my list I went
with green room and we scared you huh
well yeah I mean the thing is the stuff
that scares me the most is usually the
human cruelty stuff the stuff that's
kind of plausible and down-to-earth I
don't think any of my films have
something about legitimate human cruelty
that gets under my skin and green room
is such an intense movie about these
people sort of trapped in this dingy
little rock club surrounded by neo-nazis
that in and of itself combined with just
the sheer intensity of that movie and a
few of the things that happen again like
the violence and the gory moments are
very down to earth and there's something
again about that it's that age-old
horror thing you talk about we're like
you could watch someone get their head
sawed off and it's
thing but you know when someone gets
like sliced up with a box cutter or
whatever that hits you in a whole other
way yeah so this movie was one of the
most tense experiences I had recently
and that's why I made my list well my
number 5 picked for the exact same
reasons the ring now despite what you
might actually say about it accurate you
hear the hate comments coming in for
having this on my list when did we see
this John I wouldn't must have been like
12 13 something like that yeah I was
during a sleepover on VHS with all the
lights out thank you this movie did
scare the crap out of me and scare us
out of middle school at least there was
somewhere around there and it might have
something to do with the age I was at
during the time but there's something
specifically about Japanese types of
horror and now like this is and I know
this is gore Verbinski's film but it is
a remake with a lot of direct
inspiration from j-horror type of cinema
especially ring.you because that's where
as the remake of when I saw this film
the imagery in it would haunt me it
would get under my skin like I said this
isn't gonna come from intellectual
understanding it from the brain type the
tension the suspense the character of
samara samara is her name when she comes
out of the television as gimmicky as
that has become in the ring franchise
the first time I experienced that was
easily one of the most horrifying things
I have ever endured in my life I was
ready to crap my pants
I did not know what to do and I would
imagine that girl in so many different
places wherever I went if the lights
were off and I was alone or walking
somewhere I would just imagine this girl
coming to haunt me there's something
more about supernatural demonic stuff
maybe because we were in Catholic school
at the time and I was a devoted Catholic
of why this really affected me because
it has that level of demonic haunting
type of horror one of all the the ghost
stories out there I feel like J horror
movies typically are pretty frightening
in terms of supernatural and I think the
ring is a great choice weirdly enough
the the TV thing has never bothered me
ever but the twisted up face when they
find that girl in the closet freaked and
we did a show back in the day for
Nerdist and Fangoria
we went to like effects houses and we
went to Rick Baker studio and I went
into his showroom and he has that behind
a door so when you look behind the door
not expecting to see that you see that
and double scared me again you had a
genuine reaction the first time I did
gin I remember it so well freak me out
it wasn't even like a Oh like it was
that wasn't John yeah John just went
we're watching him and we're seeing that
desk has his hand on the desk for
watching this movie then once that
happens he goes no no I'm like what's
wrong no I just with my own mortality
like number four on my list
I chose drag me to hell which is a
favorite horror movie of mine generally
but I'll never forget the first time
that we went and watched this we went to
a test screening back and we used to go
to a lot of those we're screening a
pg-13 cut and an r-rated cut
we got the r-rated cut totally did so
much change cuz like maybe one specific
change I could think of yeah they cut
down one sneak a death yeah yeah our
rate of one sheet actually stabs the cat
but you like it yeah just really heavily
implied gross in the way yeah that movie
the first time I saw it especially was
the most I ever like jumped and like
coward but also laugh in the same moment
some of the time because like the way he
shoots that old lady mrs. ganush she
just pops up out of nowhere somehow
finds a way to make her terrifying
before any of the truly Superman stuff
starts to come out and yeah that movie
has such a sense of dread you know get
an older into Mateen years and stuff
that movie really made me jump all over
my number four pick is probably the
earliest horror film I have ever seen
this is a film that when I watch it now
I get more from it in terms of its ah
and wonder and beauty didn't register
any of that when I was a kid poultry
guys poultry guys scared the crap out of
me this is actually a contribution to
too big
years of mine clowns and dolls because
this movie had one that combined both I
don't know maybe because I was a little
boy when I saw it and a little boy just
peering over the bed and I not knowing
what's gonna happen and there was total
reaches out of grabbed I was so
terrifying to me and also when it's like
implied that the ghost is taking
advantage of the mom at one point it's
like implied it's not made clear there's
some disturbing elements to that movie
for sure yeah I mean that was just this
overall super spooky film and also the
violence in a PG film Man AB ratings
changed but the violence when the guys
like tearing off his face in that
nightmare sequence that was the kind of
image that really got under my skin
cuz nowadays I don't really find too
many movies that really scare me but
when I was a little boy this came out
before I was born I think and watching
that on my dad's laserdisc that gave me
nightmares that one though that was one
that truly haunted me yeah number three
is a film no one's talked about yet drag
me to hell well drag me down this I
think I saw before I ever visited the
Evil Dead franchise really and I think
that might have been a major
contribution as to why it terrified me
as I wasn't prepared like you would see
hints of that kind of style of direction
of Sam Raimi from like spider-man one in
spider-man 2 I knew he had done Evil
Dead I hadn't seen those movies yeah
yeah watching this one I had a very
similar experience to you which is I was
a combination of a lot of laughter and a
lot of fear I guess the main
contribution I can make of how terrified
I was similar to the ring where I would
imagine this old lady terrify me I had
to find interviews of that actress just
so I could differentiate myself from who
this woman was and go she's just an
actress citizen it's not real couldn't
find out like she's not even like the
foreign lady she's an American woman but
it is it's such good acting that I
thought they'd hire an actual foreign
actress for the role props for just
making you know a kindly lady super
spooky yeah it was a great time I
actually had a ball doing it I was a
little apprehensive going into it but
but I had a wonderful time it didn't
really help
but it did like ate a little bit and
when I was just an actress it's just an
actors that film scared the crap out of
me which is weird because I've
introduced it as some people who that's
scared by that movie it's a goofy movie
at the same time yeah I think I think
it's effective when you have no idea
where you're gonna watch I think when
you watch the trailers and you're
expecting terror fest the comedy can
ease you yeah but when when you have no
idea where you're gonna watch I think
that it's just a fright fest yeah so and
it's weird - yeah that whole eyeball in
the cake thing and it's like grips you
yeah and it's so is bang your face yeah
there's so many different tricks up its
sleeves it's jumpscared galore but
really effectively done I think number
three I'm changed in tactics and I'm
gonna go for something gross so for
number three I chose the human centipede
to full sequence you know before you go
into it I haven't even tried to watch
that movie because I've heard so much
about it ever details primarily from you
the second first second movie that I'm
like I don't even want to see it I just
don't I don't even want those images in
my mind you don't have to thing is I
have a weird predilection for ugly
cinema sometimes for nasty movies first
human centipede fascinated me because it
sort of completely subverted my
expectations and it's not the movie you
think it's gonna be the second movie is
really the movie you thought the first
movie was gonna be it's basically the
cinema equivalent of going oh yeah you
really wanted to see all that stuff here
you go I get why people hate that but I
remember the first time I watched this
movie my boss at Fangoria gave me a
blu-ray and I sat down late one night
and that is the first time in a long
time where I had to watch certain scenes
through my hands because it was getting
so depraved and so gross it's a
fascinatingly ugly movie in a way where
like the lead character is the complete
opposite of the villain from the first
he's this portly guy who barely speaks
and who's making this human centipede
with a staple gun and some duct tape and
it is a horrifying motion picture to
behold it's not perhaps the most extreme
film of all time I know some people are
gonna bust in the room be like
necromantic solo surgery
yeah fair I still have yeah I have a
copy of serbian film burning a hole in
the shelf over there that I'll watch
someday but human centipede 2 was a
pretty horrifying experience to behold
on a gross Ness and depravity scale part
of the concept for human centipede 2 was
to do everything the opposite so where
is where the first film is shot kind of
beautifully like it's very symmetrical
it's very clean it's very fluid the
second movie is in black and white it's
nasty it's handheld you know the the
photography is gross - there is a little
bit of color brown in this movie but
otherwise it's all in black and white I
don't even know that once you see it
you're like I don't think that turning
this black and white would have helped
you at all with the rating I think it
only makes it that much more upsetting
if that makes any sense and it's weird
and meta and disturbing because the
conceit again is this is just a deranged
fan of the first film who's making it
happen for real so yeah it's pretty it's
pretty scary alright number two number
two
you guys ready to really give me crap
crap right now for what I'm gonna put on
this oh boy I am ready for the hate
comments to come pouring in and like I
said this is personal life experience
Paranormal Activity I had zero idea what
I was going into I was working at some
company at the time like nothing film or
anything related group of co-workers was
like I just saw peril activity have you
heard of this is really scary and I was
like no what the hell is that so I went
with my like with my ex ex ex or
something numbered and we went to go
watch this movie and I knew nothing
about it
I hadn't seen an image I hadn't heard
anything except for a few co-workers in
the theater was packed I was like is
this like a popular movie hey people
demanded come to our city and then it
starts and I'm like I suppose like real
holistic types of deals going I stars
just getting more and more terrified
as it kept going that was a film that
literally had me on the edge of my seat
throughout the entire time yes it's
simplistic and icy in retrospect looking
back on it and revisiting it on DVD like
years later not that terrifying but at
the time with no preconceived notion
knowing nothing about it I was in an
audience and uh and I had said out loud
to my ex-girlfriend I said to her do you
know what this is about like no and then
a bunch of other people heard us say
that and everyone's like yeah we've
never heard of this I heard it was scary
I am jealous of you so yeah that was
that I think being in the theater and
and not having seen a single clip or
having any idea what was gonna happen
that really contributed and it was I was
questioning it like the first half like
is this real it feels real oh yeah yeah
yeah it felt real I'm like Blair Witch
which I still feel does not feel all
that real to me I think the acting is
great in that movie I'll still give it
that I still think the acting is really
good at that movie Paranormal Activity
is a movie that I I appreciate a lot
even though it gets a lot of crap and
the thing is I really envy your
experience because I I saw this on the
last day it was in the theater near me
alone no one was in that auditorium
except me I watched it and I the hype
really got in the way for me I was like
this is cool I'm impressed by this
I appreciate what they've done with not
much here yeah however I'm waiting for
things to happen you know and that was
my experience and it's one of those
times where I really wish I had your
experience I really wish I could have
seen it that way because I'm I'm bummed
I missed I got in there when
word-of-mouth was spreading yeah not
what the high my number two choice I
chose a film by one of my very favorite
directors Danny Boyle a film called 28
days later
it's an outbreak or zombie movie if you
want to have that argument it takes the
tropes of zombie cinema and yeah that's
one movie that I I rented even and it
still terrified me I feel like that
movie is a terrifically made horror
movie overall and that's part of what
makes it so scary is like the
situation is so immersive it's so
intense and you get to know the
characters really well you get to know
the situations really well it's a
well-conceived film but also just those
sequences where dudes ripping through
windows and like chasing after Kelly and
Murphy and stuff like that and even the
times when he's all alone in London that
movie really got under my skin and
actually the especially the first time
and even on repeat viewings gets me you
know John I'm not gonna choose to
comment on your number two because it's
my number one I have never experienced a
movie yeah I've never really watched it
actually really I saw one time in the
theatres I could tell you all about it I
wish I saw a trailer for it before I
went to church on Sunday with my family
I took a nap after church and for some
reason I really wanted to see the movie
AMC Burbank 16 had just been a new open
theater that people were loving so I
said hey mom you want to go watch 28
days later what's that
I know some scary thing whenever we come
out like 2,000 or something yeah I was
young I wasn't even a teenager so the
story on the Josh Makuta - oh we get to
the theater theater is packed my mom
needs her popcorn I go inside of the
theater there are no two seats available
together and the movies gonna start in
like a minute
like the trailers were about to wrap
doing that thing where it's the
commercial before the movie started so I
just grab some seat like a ten-year-old
kid by myself
movie starts it looks terrifying and the
digital the way it was shot what kind of
film was that on yeah wasn't it shot on
video
yeah shot on video which just makes it
way scarier yes it feels way more
authentic feels like a home video they
put together Rhett kind of borrowed a
little bit yeah yeah
and my found-footage in general yes
because it was like as a found footage
movie without being a found footage
movie just because they chose to shoot
it in that and that type of camera yeah
it has that naturalistic feeling yeah my
mom would give us the Killian Murphy and
like don't say you do get to know these
characters he's just naked on screen it
was the first time I've seen a penis in
a movie and my mom walks just can't find
me a [ __ ] of Trainspotting avatar like
no Jani Boyle is I have no idea where
these people are I think it was the
first ami movie where they're running
yeah it was yeah kick off the whole like
rabid Zambia yeah that was horrifying
because I like white zombie movies when
I was younger I thought they were cool
they always walk slow and everyday and
then and it's not like Dawn of the Dead
even Zack Snyder's version where they
run like when they run here like rage
ballistic animals yeah movie they've got
like super rabies yeah and I love the
transformation where it's like just a
little like that when the one guy I
remember it one time but I don't know
and the blood drip goes into the guy's
eye and then in like 15 seconds or
something like 30 seconds I forget it's
quick it's super quick they transform
cuz the movie I think what makes it so
effective is is equally scary as it is
heartbreaking throughout yeah and and
Zac I was a dad right yeah yeah yeah
it's scary it's heartbreaking the thing
is to the rabid people the zombie
creatures are scary and there are some
pretty scary human characters oh yeah
yeah it hits you from both angles it's
like just what life is like because of
this is scary and I appreciate 28 weeks
later but I
I don't love it anywhere near as much
out of all personal life experiences in
like a ten-year-old boys watching this
by yourself
my number one pick is a movie from the
1980s that I saw last year or the year
before or something like that I watched
recently anyway I was not expecting how
much this movie still holds up and that
is Henry portrait of a serial killer
that's our number one pick huh that
would be really got under my subscriber
it bothers ya yeah the thing about Henry
is like Henry has that scuzzy snuff
movie vibe where again in a completely
different way from a movie like Texas
Chainsaw but in a similar spirit or even
28 days later it feels like you're just
privy to this guy's life for an hour and
a half two hours your portrait you're
just watching these things unfold in the
the scenes where they're killing people
are legit distr they're just replacing
yeah it really got under my skin in a
way that actually made me feel kind of
raid of my fellow man and the contents
of the mind and stuff like that so and
it's always really stuck with me for
that reason and I always get a specific
feeling when I think back to it yeah so
I wasn't sitting there like jumpin the
whole time but it really did scare me
and it's it's it's it's a movie I point
to also because you know again there are
so many notable serial killers that we
just have very bad luck whenever I think
back on that movie I just get a feeling
that few other movies have ever given me
it's always stuck with me and yeah I
think it's a pretty scary motion picture
and Michael Rooker just disappears into
it I'm Mary Poppins yeah it's like I
think it's great but it's really hard to
recommend to people I'm like I don't
know if I want you to put yourself
through this it's the same like with a
human centipede I'm like you don't want
to watch it cool never argue with you
but yeah that movie holds up because I
feel like you could recommend all my
choices
yeah what do you have any honorable
mentions do you know Carrie was the film
that terrified me there isn't did it
make my list was because it was really
like sequences when it would come and go
like stuff with her mom and then though
the finale at the prom was pretty scary
to me and the end when she her hand pops
out and that scene where they go
shopping for prom clothes and it's all
like fast like sped up as my induction -
what a period why is she bleeding Evil
Dead the first one original yeah yeah I
think that one really scared me a lot
like the second ones spooky and fun I
think it's a better film the first ones
the one that like whoa yeah yeah and
it's shrill - which really is unsettling
The Shining was a very uncomfortable
experience for me but it was also the
first couple times I saw I was really
young so I didn't love it because it's
really Stanley Cooper's super slow so
really some time to appreciate dread
really start happening likewise for the
Exorcist same applicable thing that's a
film I I feel like I really appreciate
it when I was like closer to being an
adult
I would definitely also say scream these
films might arguably my favorite horror
movie of all time guess one more that
had some really frightening stuff in the
twists a film where the twist scared me
and normally a twist is just cool and oh
how did I not see that coming this twist
caught under my skin and that was the
others that that twist was like actually
the others made my a list of honorable
mentions as well it's one of my favorite
horror movies actually one of my
favorite yeah ghost movies in general
yeah I chose that the ring I put on my
honorable mentions as well a house on
Haunted Hill I know I harp on that one a
lot and as a child that movie freaked me
out and is one of my like formative
horror movie experiences I lost some
sleep over that so I felt the need to
mention it here leavel dead for sure The
Hills Have Eyes remake - I thought was
it's pretty scary pretty pretty shouts
out to Hellraiser - like I don't think
it's terrifying but in terms of all
those classic 80s movies that we harken
back to those those franchises that's
the one I saw that that did make me feel
kind of yeah inside when I first watched
it alright guys I hope you enjoyed our
video we like doing these special more
long videos every once in a while so
thank you Tony McGuire for the request
give us a good excuse to do one of these
things that's not so trending right now
so thank you what are some of the horror
movies that scared you guys the most
doesn't have to be your favorite just
the ones that actually scare you leave a
good comment down below maybe gave you a
nightmare huh made you lose a little
sleep Oh
pee a little bit subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up you can follow us on
social media links in the description
box and hey yes we have a patreon but
also what you can do is download and
follow us on the Stardust oh I'm hearing
about it it's an app that allows you to
do 30-second reactions for any film TV
show or movie so sometimes we might not
do a review of a show but you will give
our instant reactions on it and plus
we're covering some like older films
that we just happen to stumble across or
whatever so yeah follow us there and we
really appreciate